President Trump is facing criticism for
backing Saudi Arabia despite
intelligence that reportedly shows the
Saudi Crown Prince may have directed the
murder of columnist Jamal khashoggi mr.
Trump stated quote it could very well be
that the Crown Prince had knowledge of
this tragic event maybe he did maybe he
didn't in any case our relationship is
with the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia CBS
News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell is a former
deputy and acting director of the CIA
good morning good morning happy
Thanksgiving happy Thanksgiving to you
what do you make of both the president's
position and the fact that he put it in
a press release there's a long history
of US presidents putting priority on
national security and strategic
relationships over human rights and
democratic freedoms President Obama did
that in 2013 with a coup in Egypt where
he refused to call it a coup so that he
wouldn't have to cut off all aid right
he did it much more elegantly
than President Trump just did it and
this is an important relationship with
the Saudis but what I would have
suggested to the president is that you
do need to put some sort of sanctions on
Saudi Arabia to send a message that you
cannot get away with something like this
but not not so many sanctions that you
break the relationship so you find the
right balance the president did not do
that here what message does this send
though to folks inside the CIA and folks
at the CIA is potentially trying to
recruit when the president so publicly
seems to distance himself from their
findings and this isn't the first time
the unfortunate the unfortunate thing is
that this is public right that somebody
leaked the CIA judgment and then it
became a public discussion usually these
things aren't discussed publicly there
are plenty of times where presidents
disagree with the analysis that's
presented to them when I was briefing
President Bush every morning he would
frequently say Michael I disagree with
this and then we would discuss it so
it's just usually not public so what's
important here is that the CIA continued
to put its view forward one of the
important things to me here is is not
the judgment about whether MBS was
involved but what did the CIA tell the
president of
about the implications of no sanctions
of letting him get away with it verse
the implications of putting some sort of
sanctions on to send a message that's
the analysis that I'd like Michel what
message does that send because I think a
lot of people are struggling with this
that a person can be lured to the
embassy that you can be hacked up you
can be slaughtered that the company I
can lie about it and that we will still
stand by that a lie what message does
that send to the world and what's to
prevent this from happening again so I
think it sends the wrong message what
the President did sends the wrong
message right and that's why I'm fully
in support of some sort of sanctions
that sends a message to NBS and by the
way behind the scenes you know back
channel I would say to him this is
strike one
and in this game of baseball there are
only two strikes so if you do this again
we're gonna be in a very different place
so I do think it's important to send a
message that people can't get away with
this and that's why I would have done
some sort of sanctions but implicit in
the president's remarks is that you can
slight strike two and three you're still
gonna get away with it because and
here's what I want to focus on Iran
basically the president saying Iran is
the big game here and yes this is bad
but this is let's keep our eye on the
most national security ball Iran so is
that right does he have it right in
terms of the primacy of the Iranian
threat that South that Saudi Arabia is
helping the u.s. so I think there's two
critical aspects to our strategic
relationship with Saudi Arabia one is
Iran Iran does want to be the hegemonic
power in the Middle East and we need to
push back against that and we need the
Saudis to help us the second is we need
societal and religious reform in Saudi
Arabia in order to dampen extremism that
continues to flood the world well as if
now it looks like NBS will be at the g20
next week we'll see if the two leaders
do meet Michael we would always love to
have you more but people can listen to
your podcast intelligence matters from
this issue so many other important
matters you see you all happy holidays
thank you